primero considera la expresión para
menos 5 más la cantidad de 4 veces x
ahora toma el producto de menos 8 y esta
expresión y entonces suma 6 hagamos esto
paso a paso primero vamos a tener esta
expresión menos 5 más algo tenemos para
empezar menos 5 más la cantidad de 4
veces x la cantidad de 4 veces x que va
a ser simplemente 4x menos 5 más 4x s es
esta primera expresión ahora tome el
producto de menos 8 el producto de menos
8 menos 8 que multiplica a esta
expresión el producto de menos 8 y esa
expresión vamos a marcarla aquí esa
expresión que es menos 54 x xi ahora
tomamos el producto de menos 8 y esa
expresión esto va a ser menos 8 que
multiplica a menos 5 más 4x este es
menos 8 este es esa expresión el
producto el producto
esos dos podemos poner el signo
multiplicación ahí o dejarlo indicado
implícitamente con el producto de menos
8 y esa expresión y entonces suma de 6 y
entonces sumarle 6 es decir a todo eso
le vamos a sumar 6 + 6
todo esto lo podemos indicar como menos
8 se abre el paréntesis menos 5 + 4 x y
finalmente más 6 hagamos uno más primero
considera la expresión la suma de 7 la
suma de 7 y esto va a ser 7 más el
producto de menos 2 y x el producto de
menos 2 y x esto va a ser menos 2 x 7 +
menos 2 x esa es la primera expresión lo
cual podemos escribir también como esto
es exactamente igual a 7 menos 2x estas
dos son equivalentes qué expresión será
4 más
la cantidad de dos veces esa expresión
esa cantidad que vamos a sumar vamos a
indicarle aquí entre paréntesis la
cantidad de dos veces la cantidad de dos
veces lo voy a poner en amarillo la
cantidad de dos por esa expresión esta
expresión
vamos a ponerle en azul esta expresión
que tenemos aquí así es que la cantidad
que vamos a sumar va a ser dos veces esa
expresión que es 7 menos 2x y así hemos
concluido